cem özdemir kam mit dem fahrrad alle
limousinen fuhren fort klima das ganz
große thema im wahlkampf aber auch ziele
gesetzt jetzt in der regierung und da
sehen wir erkennen dass ich da auf dem
gepäckträger noch die ernennungsurkunde
bringt nochmal kurz zu helm auf nochmal
einmal der römer ja genau hallo da bin
ich und dann fährt er beim radeln wieder
zurück in den bundestag werden alle
anderen mit den limousinen abfuhren und
kam so konnten wir beobachten da auch
richtig gut gelaunt an denn das
natürlich ist eine aktion die schafft
natürlich auch aufmerksam mit
aufmerksamkeit beantwortet uns einmal
die frage auf wenn man nicht in den kopf
von schmerzen mehr reinschauen kann wie
viel inszenierung steckt dahinter wie
viel überzeugungen steckt dahinter wir
sind im revier welcher noch sagen gott
sei dank hat er nicht einen cent noch im
mund nicht denn das sind ja andere
spielchen mit denen er sich inszeniert
hat ja er wird das alles politisch
begründen und sagen ja es wichtig und
warum brauchen dienstwagen und blei war
immer mit dem aber natürlich ist es eine
ganz kalkulierte sache hier ich finde es
ein bisschen überflüssig weil es jetzt
noch nicht mal verkehrsminister sondern
landwirtschaftsminister hätte auch einem
traktor vorfahren können wenn eh traktor
also das sind so dinge die sind wirklich
für die galerie gemacht so menschen am
ersten tag also bestätigt eigentlich die
die die größten vorbehalte die man
gegenüber haben die politik auch im
showgeschäft ja aber es muss ich sagen
beim polen des präsidenten diese hape
kerkeling ist ja auch mal vor gefahren
dass wissen wir also so erinnert mich
ein bisschen daran also an so was also
wissen natürlich auch als er damit
hervorruft ja es sollte halt und dadurch
kollegial gegenüber den anderen es gibt
ja es gibt genügend minister die dürfen
nicht fahrrad fahren und die stehen
jetzt einfach dämlich da und sicherheit
ja also die dürfe aus sicherheitsgründen
nicht fahren der bauern minister ja gut
der ist jetzt also jetzt nicht so in der
bedrohungslage so weit oben dass er
schon ab dem ersten tag voll schutz
braucht es ist ein tag aber wir können
es nicht an meckern wenn
nicht dann auch meckern dann seine
fahrer ankommen was ich gut gefunden
hätte wenn der rest des kabinetts
einfach mit dem sammeltaxi mit mit einem
band vor gefahren der klassenfahrt zu
zum bundespräsidenten zum urkunde
abholen und dann fährt man zurück und
dann relevant vom reichstag die paar
hundert meter ein ministerium rein dann
bin ich absolut dagegen auch gar nicht
erst anfangen weil aber gab's minister
sind minister manche sind sicherheits
geschützt sie brauchen ihre panzer in
museen und der rest hat einen anspruch
auf eine solche minister limousine und
ich finde wir sollten nicht anfangen bei
den repräsentanten unseres staates ist
solche dinge in frage zu stellen wenn er
mit fahrradfahren will in zukunft immer
gerne hier ist es bin ich absolut beide
unkollegial weil er genau weiß dass die
anderen das nicht dürfen